let's get out and say straight away that most
of what you see online that's claiming to be
deep fake isn't deep fake right it's some
kind of visual effects of some description
right people being made to look younger in movies
that isn't at the moment done with deep networks
they're not that good yet you know there's been
some very impressive demonstrations how much of
that is deep learning isn't always disclosed
but i'm really interested in the topic because
i don't think that deep fakes are that convincing
yet but i think they will be convincing in five or
ten years and then we have some serious problems
defects usually trained with a lot of pictures
of one person and another person and a network
learns to basically convert them over now one
of the things about being on computer file is
we have quite a back catalogue of videos of for
example me and steve so i had a go at this i
trained it up and it's the stuff of nightmares
yeah so they were developing all this it doesn't
work amazingly all the time it doesn't handle
you know when the view goes off and things
like this but on the other hand for something
where i basically just put in a bunch of source
material it just kind of did it you know that's
pretty impressive there's a lot of stuff a lot of
talk about gans and things like this actually a
lot of deep fake isn't gans but they are encoder
decoder networks like we've talked about before
we have videos on gans and we have a video on
auto encoders or encoder decoders depending on
what your preference is the problem we're trying
to solve is that we're trying to take a face
and turn it into a different face right or it's
basically just trying to draw someone's face on
top of an existing one right and that allows you
to take a source video locate the face in it in
each frame and then paint on the new face right
and theoretically replace someone now there's a
lot more to faking than this you've got to do the
voice the hair and things like this right and one
of the problems if i'm trying to transfer my face
onto someone who doesn't look anything like me
is that it doesn't look good even if the face
is good most people who've taken interest this
will have seen this famous tom cruise look-alike
video it's very very impressive right how much is
visual effects and the actual deep learning i
don't know but the actual looks a lot like tom
cruise to begin with right it wasn't going
to work with me as the bass how do we train
a deep fake right so let's suppose we're taking
person a and we're trying to turn them into person
b so we need to first collect a load of faces of
each person and to do that we can use existing
deep networks so for example there are networks
which will find the key landmarks on your face
there are networks which will detect face we've
done face recognition before and so what that
means is you can take a video or series of videos
and find a line and crop out the faces essentially
automatically and that makes your training process
much much easier so you do this and let's say
you collect i know 5 000 pictures of me and 5 000
pictures of steve right and you crop right down to
the face level because if you have a load of arm
waving in it that's a much harder generate image
generation problem which is for another day right
if the person is front and center and just looking
like this then maybe you can get away a few images
but if they're looking and doing this and they're
smiling and you know facial expressions for the
network to learn all those different mappings
you need lots more data not to mention things
like lighting changes at different areas and stuff
right so this is person a i don't know why i've
drawn a full person on here because that doesn't
make sense right this is person b so these are
cropped images of faces not not all people right
um sort that out in post for me please so the deep
network we're using here is called an auto encoder
right i often refer to it as an encoder decoder
right because i just it's just in the literature
that i use that that seems to be what it's called
but it's not really important the important thing
is you have a piece of network here which down
samples your image makes it smaller but also
extracts interesting features and it turns it
into features and this is called the encoder so
this is an e for encoder right and we have another
encoder here now actually these are the same one
these have the exact same neural network weights
they're trained in the same way and we have
features here an example of this kind of network
is the one when we talked about face recognition
trying to take someone's face and put it into that
space where you can just determine who they are
right that's essentially what this is doing this
is going to be some 500 1000 2000 digit barcode
should we say representing all the interesting
aspects of their face then we have a decoder so
the decoders is essentially the exact opposite it
makes the image bigger again and returns it back
to the original size and we're trying to produce
another face which is an exact copy of this first
one right so this is the decoder now what's
interesting about these deep fake technologies
is the encoder is shared right which means that
essentially the same encoder is used to turn a
into features and b into features but the decoder
is unique to each person so this might be mike's
decoder this might be steve's decoder and so
how you train this is you just put in a load of
images of me you've put them through this encoder
decoder and you try and get as close a copy of me
out now if you think this isn't an image in here
this is sort of high level feature information
so this is essentially compression right it's
it's got to down sample this whole image into
a very small feature space of just the most really
important information and then it's going to turn
it back into an image and the same here it's going
to take a picture of steve or someone else going
to down sample them into the feature space and
then it's going to up sample them back because the
whole point of this network is you're trying to
make sure this matches this and this matches this
if your feature space isn't a good representation
of your face you're not going to be able to do
that right so that's why the features end up
useful right this is what auto encoders do
they turn your input into a fit into a latent
space or a feature space and then you turn this
back into the image the encoder is a set of
instructions that take a face and summarize
it and then the decoder is takes that summary
and turns it back into an image and it's going
to include things like orientation and stuff like
this now how do we actually turn me into steve or
vice versa right all we do we train this all up so
we make sure a looks like the output of a b looks
like the output of b there are other generative
adversarial versions of this you could use right
but this is just nice and straightforward and then
all we do suppose we want to turn steve into me
we put in a picture of steve right we encode
it into this shared feature representation
which is you know what what poses he has he
got but then we use mike's decoder so we switch
this decoder out for my one we turn an image of
the person we're trying to change we turn them
into the feature space and then we use someone
else's decoder to return them to a different face
right that's how it works and then you get a nice
picture of me out nice is relative right um and
you know i've trained this up and it works pretty
well right it's it's a little bit a little bit
weird wireless networking older than you didn't
believe it was super straightforward right i
just got a load of videos from you right which
downloading them was the slowest part and then i
basically it automatically extracted all the faces
aligned them all nicely and then i essentially
just trained it from there and i played around
with a couple of networks involved read up from
what they did but basically it it very it holds
your hand through the whole process and then at
the end you can put in a video and it'll give
you out a video with my face instead of steve's
there's obviously a lot of problems with it right
first of all the networks are still not quite high
resolution enough to deal with 1080 and 4k video
you know i didn't put enough training data i put
in quite a bit but not enough not varied enough if
you were really committed to providing incredibly
impressive output you would need to pay a lot more
attention and train it for a lot longer than i did
right i was just seeing how things go it heats up
my whole house this graphics card when i train on
it so um i was i was too hot so i turned it off
this seems like a bit of a one-trick pony right
well actually um so deep fake all this sort of
image to image conversion which is really what
it is it's quite common outside of faces
as well so for example satellite imagery
right people are using it for mri to try and
convert between one kind of scanner and another
because then you can get a deep network
that works on both and things like this
there's loads of times where style transfer
which is a sort of what this is a subset of
um is really really useful right so there's a huge
amount of research happening not just in faces
but in other domains as well right some of it's
like this some of it's using stargand cycle gan
you know it depends right um but yeah this is a
pretty broad uh broad area for me these networks
are pretty standard networks that i use day to
day but they're somewhat interesting right but
i'm interested in what happens to this in a few
years time when these networks start to become
really really good right because you know the pace
at which deep learning is improving is impressive
right no not at every task right it doesn't
just solve everything but you've got to imagine
that for low quality cctv the kind of stuff that
needs to hold up in court or something like this
it's not going to be that many years before we
can completely replace faces or other things
objects in those scenes right and we have to be
prepared for that we're long since past the idea
that you could put a lid on this right and i'm not
saying that would even be a good thing right so
for example i used a github repository called face
swap to do my training like really cool download
it have a go for legitimate reasons please but
it has something like 30 000 stars on github
10 000 forks you know people are using this
in bulk right and and this is not the only one
you can't you can't ban this kind of
technology because it's just academic
discovery right and the other thing is that if
you try and ban it you end up in a situation
where only a certain people who already understand
it still have access to some technology and no one
else can access it right and that isn't that isn't
going to solve any problems like you could imagine
a situation where only people with resources could
tamper videos not everyone else and then you've
got a whole different set of problems you've not
really got a solution and anyway in the list of
things it says please don't use this for illegal
activities right problem solved i mean no like
i mean deep fake has obviously been amused because
it is used a lot for illegitimate activity right
for putting faces on things for faking politicians
words and stuff i would prefer to focus not on the
fact that it's being used for those things but
some kind of solutions we might think about as to
how we actually fix those problems because they're
not going to stop just because we ask nicely right
we have to think about you know in 10 years time
when you can't tell the difference between a and b
what do we do then like can you still use video
evidence right can you trust anything you see
on a social media site that has someone talking
if they can fake video and audio perfectly well
no not really right so there are some solutions to
this that people are exploring so the most obvious
one would just be you this is a problem caused
by deep learning right we'll solve it with deep
learning so we just take a video or a picture we
put it into a classifier trained on deep fakes and
say is it fake or not right this is you know
the adversarial approach it works okay i mean
it's going to be dependent on getting enough video
data will it work on the videos of me don't know
probably but will it generalize i don't know
what you end up happening is that people are
researching better techniques to perform image
conversion and then someone develops a better
way of detecting it and you just go like this and
the whole thing you know it's like virus detection
it's just like antivirus and virus detection
right the viruses become more sophisticated
they they encrypt themselves and things like
this and it becomes harder to check and so on
you have to come up with new new techniques
so i think that deep learning does have
a role to play in trying to detect stuff like this
i suppose what i'm wondering about is what happens
when they become so good that it is impossible to
tell the difference right now i don't i don't know
how likely that is but i would say pretty
likely given that given that for an image
we're only talking about a few hundred pixels
across right you can make pretty convincing
facilities using cgi already right so doing this
automatically does not seem out of a question
i think that probably cryptography
has a pretty big role to play
you know there are mechanisms in cryptography like
mesh authentication codes to stop messages being
tampered with right there's digital certificates
to verify ownership of some kind of file or
message right you could imagine that if these
things were built into like cctv cameras
you couldn't tamper with the message because
you wouldn't be able to recompute the signature
and things like this right i've not thought
this through right there with people in the
comments do discuss it in the comments right and
tell me why i'm wrong but it seems to me that
cryptographic techniques to stop things being
tampered with and make sure you know where things
have come from and who signed what they have a
role to play in trying to stop some of this i
think right those things don't exist in this area
yet we have stuff like digital water marking but
it's all pretty low key more research is going
to be needed here pretty pretty soon i'd say
cipher text that we'll be breaking later does
it honestly start with zeus as in conrad's use
yeah the reality of random yeah yeah yeah
yeah um you see all kinds of words in the
random ciphertext and they mean absolutely
nothing another row of characters became
as it were normal to the paper and could be
AUTOMATIC CAPTIONS - Manually Published